good morning millennium welcome back to
the morning totes Jack and I both have a
little bit of a nasal situation so just
bear with the nasality today if you can
I'm on the tail end of a very thick
weekend well that means I caught what
you got and I'm at the fresh start of a
brand new cold design I was watching a
manís and story and she did a poll is
everyone sick or is it just us so maybe
there's something going around and it
did start with my allergies it's like my
allergies made me sneeze gave me a cold
gave me everything else so it is allergy
season which is nice like everyone
medicine being sick in California
doesn't mean anything to us but it's the
season there is such thing as the post
Coachella flu yeah and I believe I am
currently suffering the post stagecoach
the or post the post Coachella
California filled the post
ngo flu yeah and that's what I'm
suffering from currently I'm doing
better I have it's now in my throat you
know so it's phlegm season you know it's
funny it's better than it's not season
that's true you know how like whenever
you're sick with different types of
sickness you're like oh no this is the
worst type of sickness when you live
bellyache like you have the runs it's
like there's nothing worse but then it's
a give strep throat and you can't
swallow you're like oh no this is
totally totally worse than that oh I'm
the complete opposite I'm like but at
least it's not it's so positive I almost
and now it's like I'm not even in that
much pain I'm just like complaining but
my ear is killing me like it's mucus job
and I'm like this is the worst of all
the illnesses and honestly please make
your hurts so bad also when I'm so sick
when I'm in it then like and I'm on my
worst day I'll be like well at least
this is the worst thing they can only go
up from here no that's such a great
outlook on life I literally have the
complete opposite I believe that's what
they call glass half-full
yes and I'm much more of a glass half
empty kind of yeah but apparently you
suffer pain like in a way that no human
ever house okay and you know that
redheads technically have the lowest
tolerance for pain I feel like
biologically I am in more pain at all
times than you are
it's that crazy to think about that you
would never know it no that's not that's
not true yes it's like okay redheads are
prone to like if someone punches me and
punches you same amount of force it will
hurt me more but here's the thing it
hurts me more so how can you argue with
that you know what like you don't know
what I'm feeling no no I know
exactly how you're feeling because I
know I'm feeling 35 times worse maybe
you're ready
maybe you got that gene Oh a little
crossover of the DNA combination hey no
next week this week actually but you
know we do have an ad because today's
episode did you know was sponsored by
Robin Hood I do not know what that is so
exciting it is so exciting and thank you
Robin Hood for being continued partner
of the toast we truly appreciate you
need to make us better and more Chartier
Robin Hood is an investing app that lets
you buy and sell stocks ETFs options and
cryptos all commissioned free while
other brokerages charge up to $10 for
every trade Robin Hood jet doesn't
charge any Commission fees so you can
trade stocks and keep all your profits
plus there's no account minimum deposit
needed to get started so you can start
investing at any level I started with
$10 the simple intuitive design of Robin
Hood makes investing easy for newcomers
and experts alike views easy to
understand charts market data and a
place to trade in just four taps on your
smart phone you can also view stock
collections such as a hundred most
popular with Robin Hood you can learn
how to invest in the market as you build
your portfolio discover new stocks track
the favorite companies and get a new
custom notification for price movements
so you never missed the right moment to
invest Robin Hood is giving listeners of
the morning toast a free stock like
Apple Ford or sprint to help you build
your portfolio sign up a toast dot Robin
Hood com I just had a great idea today
snitches birthday snitch wherever you're
sleeping right now happy birthday we
know you're sleeping good because it
gave you some CBD last night
ODB oh nice and we had like such a fun
day yesterday in honor of Cinco de
snitch
but we should get her some stocks for
her birthday Lacan yay yeah because all
she really wants his cash and like
that's so tacky it's so tacky and like
it just
she runs through it you know yeah it's
tacky oh but like if we set her up on
Robin Hood with some stock or like a
long-term bond with a hot yield
I think the yields would be so high I
think so Ted that's actually a very nice
gift Connie got that for Kim like
obviously we wouldn't be getting mark on
million dollar bonds even more like a
hundred dollars you never know if you
bet on the Kentucky Derby horse you
would have made two dollars for every
dollar no but the one that won was sixty
five to one well the one that won was in
disqualified and his for the one that
won the one that won I thought it was it
was sixty five to one that's what Ben
told me okay Ben knows doesn't know a
lot but Ben knows everything about
gambling well we have story on it so
we'll get to the the specifics it long
has happened this weekend / specifically
last night
having last night I caught up on a lot I
watched a lot of movies I watched three
Netflix movies that we've been talking
about that I would love to discuss we'll
do that at the end of the show but um
I've been so behind on like teen romance
films and now I feel adult young adult
like I wasn't following Maia Mitchell
and I'm still not but I might soon
you know I have lots of thoughts on Maia
Mitchell we'll talk about her at the end
of the show we'll talk about Game of
Thrones we'll talk about my big tour now
it's been at 12 p.m. Eastern Standard
Time which I think everyone knows what
it is but I don't care cuz I'm really
excited and I watch Beverly Hills did
you know okay okay what happened no I
didn't they went to the lunch where were
we
we were in a church Oh Vegas no I don't
watch either one okay i watch last night
um so we can talk about it later this
week and I surrender watch New York but
anyways are you eating it's time let me
say am I ready um I guess yeah okay I'm
ready okay it's time for the fast five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast first story the big story
of the day Meghan Markel and Prince
Harry announce arrival of the Royal baby
boy on Instagram you know it's so funny
like I wouldn't consider this the story
of the day I mean like everyone else
would I'm just like so much more
invested in this Busy Philipps
cancellation okay yes what I'm happy for
what they want and it's royal baby
announcement I mean do you think it's
just a coincidence that it sounds
cinches birthday okay do you think it's
a coincidence it's on the Met Gala day
because I have a thought like you know
like years ago
there was literally no shot in hell
Meghan Markel would have ever been
invited to the Met Gala this is the
first year where not only she eligible
she might be too famous to go and she
couldn't go cause she had to give birth
like do you think she like hates our kid
a little bit because no I finish it the
way the Met Gala Oh contraire it's like
I couldn't go to the Met Gala ever and
now I'm bigger than the Met guy and now
my baby is bigger than the Met Gala my
placenta is heavier than the Met Gala
has any Royals ever been to Temecula I
really feel like they're too famous for
it I feel like well I don't know if you
know Windsor family has been I feel like
Princess Di could have gone no she would
have like she was Thursday like for sure
she was like the original answer no
totally but still influencing people to
the stash some of that like I feel like
Katie Spencer will be there this year
yeah yeah I mean like Newsom said Larry
yeah top tier idk Beatrice and Eugenie
like for sure if they were invited they
could go yeah if they wanted to go they
could go yeah I don't know about the
Windsors I don't know about the ones to
see that okay so she gave birth to a boy
speculation on name ooh um Margo oh I
like that what about what about Claudia
they were there will literally never be
a royal person names Claudia no but
there might be one named Margot named
after princess actually maybe there'll
be like a in a monarchy like in
somewhere Latin where they would name
Claudia yeah that's it like Oh banish me
like Barcelona do they have Queens oh
yeah they actually I think there is a
princess of Queen Claudia yes she's
right here hey I think the name will be
like Arthur oh I don't know and they
have an Arthur and a George and Arthur
George Oh Kardashian influence sprinkle
in their socks all over Kensington
Palace I had seen some like three royal
baby name suggestions that like we're
deeply rooted in Lewis or do they use
that one already
actually David's not a good woman
because he abdicated the throne wait the
third Chauncey
the third child of Kate what's her name
his name Louis oh yes so they can't do
that name no they could do Arthur yeah
you said that already
yeah maybe People magazine has a
speculation no People magazine having
important details no it can't be
no but they all they have is speculation
yeah no I saw I saw Arthur I saw Arthur
I saw what okay
royal baby I should go to Melanie
Bromley's Twitter for this oh you're a Z
to conference Melanie Bromley in and
she'll tell us everything i'll baby name
predictions we should bet on this yeah
Oh Theodore I think actually oh man oh
really I would love because then there
would finally be someone on the planet
who is worthy of the name Theo just as
much as Theo is here are the three that
I saw James love Edward my Arthur yeah
no it's names like Arthur and Edward
it's hard to be an infant and Bea Arthur
because you just expect a thing or like
Arthur no but then you respect Arthur to
roll in your like Arthur you just expect
Arthur to roll in with his rolodex and
his tennis brief
case you get his bifocals no that's why
I'm not respondent Arthur meme of the
character yeah yeah I thought it was
like a historical joke about King Arthur
I'm like I don't know just a cartoon
agreed it's hard to be baby Arthur but
what's your worldly to be whatever you
want but I like the name James I like
the name James to interesante
you know I just make it a little always
like off the beaten path right different
she's like if there's speculation she's
not doing it like with George that was
one of the top names that people thought
it was gonna be and of course Kate
follows all the rules and she did it but
Megan's a little different now she's
moving to Africa she moved out of the
panel she wore an ugly wedding dress
like maybe she's not gonna choose and
historically royal name but also Kate's
first male boy is going to be king and
he has to have a king's name and George
is a king same like Meghan doesn't have
that pressure sure she's gonna be off
the beaten path well because she is okay
whatever do you want placemats or no
okay sure um obviously I'm gonna put my
money on Theodore cuz that name is
probably so much luck
okay actually no I'm gonna put it on
MUFON my name phone start time yes
okay I'm gonna Thea you're gonna see a
door okay I'm gonna put my money on
Arthur just because it was the name that
stuck out to me winner has made the
other loser has made the other $10 okay
I could yeah it's nothing crazy I could
swing that yeah I mean I have a mighty
big Darrin we're trying to get arrested
on this show I did have a mighty big
dinner for five in which two people only
brought money well because you chose the
restaurant it was cash only and you said
it was acceptable like to venmo the
person and we did oh it's funny Hannigan
mmm but no cuz you didn't pay that as
much as you thought you paid for two
people yeah and then you told Margo
LuAnn that she didn't have to pay you I
did yeah so you did that to yourself oh
she's a vendor Chris coming at her but
very soon I was so drunk last night and
like honestly I swear there was vodka in
my penne alla vodka cuz I got more drunk
after dinner like usually of two bowls
of pasta will sober you up for me I was
flying you were high on life do you want
to hear the saddest thing that happened
to me yes I know this no you don't know
is it about the cab it is but you don't
know the specifics okay so after we left
it was raining all day yesterday but
then it obviously came down when we were
leaving the restaurant and there was no
way to leave just go on the sidewalk you
to like walk around the corner waiting
for our uber I put the pin in the world
they moved again to the wrong spot I
couldn't move it again and then the
driver was confused tried to cancel got
an uber and then it was saying was
dropping someone off on its way to me he
thought but then that went away and then
he was just here I check the license
plate I go up to the car in the ring and
there's people in the car
you still haven't dropped them off he's
like all the way around how did you mind
hi my guy into the uber everyone else
was there Eddie home in their pajamas
that's a terrible feeling it was so
horrible I couldn't believe it was
happening to me oh my god I can't
believe you there's nothing more
important than opening an uber to ever
like someone's in there I didn't open
the door but it was even sadder I was
like that is so [ __ ] sad it was
pathetic
so anyways don't mind me I'm trying
desperately to pop my ears oh you know
when you hear that like in your ear yeah
the crackle snap crackle pop you need a
piece of gum why don't I yawning [ __ ]
I've been calling all morning naturally
well Mazel talked to the happy couple
the new parents and excited for them I'm
excited for that nature yes they need
they need the world to start talking
about something else other than like
their marriage hewed yeah and also like
their they need cousins with the
Windsors so that they can all get along
for the children yeah you know now it's
like Georgia so much older than his
cousins will be he's gonna be like he's
eosin he's gonna be like a weird older
cousin yeah Mason yeah
Charlotte's the Penelope Louise the rain
Arthur is north yeah no I was just
thinking that I can't it used to be that
I couldn't say the word North without
thinking of the Kardashians now I can't
think of the word North without thinking
of gay kids enough yeah my brother's
brother this is my favorite word that
they pronounce it Game of Thrones like
because it's BR you th brothers is Sansa
good Nancy not ladies also the way that
it's interesting to watch how they
pronounce Sansa from the beginning of
the session because they were calling
her Sansa yeah they were eyes like
almost Suns er I think actually in the
North you said that in one of the recent
episodes number I was watching back I
think in the north they always called
her Sansa and now that we're spending
more time in the north like Cersei
always called her Sansa yeah but in the
north she's Sansa and then ayah is like
get even shorter yeah no it's a the
shortest name
she's a from pretty low water this aria
has a name from pretty little iris who
which is also why so many people are
naming their babies Aria America why
it's not a name for me no because it's
like I'm not that much of a throw head
and I want to talk about Drake for a
second because we're at the VMAs BIOS
was like each it's so random where he
made his thirsty speech where he was
like in shadow jars dogs putting it work
yeah yeah I was so thirsty yeah we were
talking about it last night and he was
like that was so cool I was like it was
a little thirsty like it's the most
watched show and the where else he was
just trying to like be relatable and he
was like no he's just so cool I was like
okay agree to disagree
then we're laying in bed he shows me
this picture on Instagram of Drake in a
jersey that says are you with the wolf
and the Air Jordan logo but arias
jumping and stabbing and then there are
shaq admitted he okay that is so loser
yeah it was like you're big and like you
don't have to struggle to stoop this low
no you don't everyone loves you it's
fine just keep doing your work right
okay are you ready for our next story
well you were born ready for this story
okay he cancels Busy Philipps
talk show busy tonight and the way that
it was announced was via Twitter her
Twitter which was nice they gave her
like the the platform like it didn't
come out and she had to like explain she
tweeted it and I have so many thoughts
because I've been like on this Busy
Philipps like thing since the show came
out and I was feeling really conflicted
because like the show was bad it's
undeniably not a great show but like I'm
really happy that there's finally like a
woman in late night who's got her like
really she got her show because people
were loving her Instagram and like
that's all one Instagram or can hope for
you know yeah but I was complete too
because it's like she's out here
speaking for people women on the
internet and I just don't feel
represented by this show and then I
would watch it and just feel so highly
uncomfortable like with the singing and
the nightgowns and just like the inside
jokes that like we were supposed to get
but we didn't um so now that's been
cancelled I'm feeling I'm feeling again
conflicted because it's a bad show and
bad shows shouldn't stay on television
but it's like sad that this platform
which was like supposed to be like for
us you know like it's like oh the
Millennials again they can't get their
[ __ ] together yeah it's a you never know
when we're gonna be given another chance
now right and it's also like I did feel
maybe canceling it was a little bit of a
jump like did you need to be on five
nights a week for 10 minutes every night
no one 30-minute
sowed a week is good enough I totally
agree with and I don't think she should
have been cancelled immediately like
it's virtually impossible like watch
opens live was on once a week people
loves it so much I think they went to
like three times a week and now they
went to five times a week which is like
a normal progression but just start at
five times a week you're literally
setting someone up for failure
I agree unless it's just like such a
great show right and it wasn't which it
was it but the people are having like
this surreal reactions to this and
invite people I mean the toasters like
they feel either so harshly one way like
good cheese socks I hope she ever has a
career again I find this so hard see one
right and then one person be like
imagine a fizzy ride this week just no
but then the people who like like the
show like made good points and it's just
like it does stick like that this was
supposed to be for us you know yeah but
I feel like E is constantly turning out
programming for us I don't think this is
gonna be our last shot like lady gets
out here doing wonders for the finale
wondering if bleeding is gonna get more
nights a week or nightly pop it's gonna
get more night so you think that nightly
pops you get more next week and nightly
pop started out as one week and then it
went to two and like normal normal
progression lady things not live though
and some elite late show so I think once
a week is perfect for them and I just
like loved it and I ran into Becca Tobin
in the bathroom at stagecoach and she
recognized me they always love her I
love her so much at first I was just
like trying to be normal and then when I
got out of the sauce mode that was me
yesterday which emoji wheel oh yeah oh
my god I ran into Jameela Jamil she we
were standing outside so while she was
walking in and I like was so wasted and
I just like stumbled in and like
attacked her and she was definitely
feeling very threatened by me but like I
didn't care I just like told her you
know I've never met someone had been
like starstruck by an activist do you
know anything like usually it's like a
singer a but like she's like a true
acting like I'm struck by your activism
yeah like she's also an actress but like
I am here for her activism and I was
just like I didn't even know how do you
how do you compliment someone's activism
yeah I was like you're doing such great
work I love it so much like oh yeah like
that was how and she definitely I was an
animal and we took a picture in the
lobby and I got yelled at because
there's no pictures in so house and I
apologized profusely but I had to buzzer
oh god we've got an email struggling
worded email I got a strongly worded
email coming my way and you know what I
deserved it totally okay any additional
thoughts on busy tonight well I do have
one thought obviously you know can't
help but make this about us and of
course obviously you know this would be
the morning to us if we weren't making
things about us write this one
millennial venture fails I understand
and it is sad because like she does seem
like a really nice lady yeah and that's
why she liked the show but it was like
just because she's a nice lady I'm funny
I'm Instagram doesn't mean that she is a
late-night host you know of course um
but looks like there's an opportunity
yes and this millennial venture did fail
and might I suggest to e the next time
you go off on a millennial venture maybe
have some Millennials that's just that
is just my two cents and I will leave it
at that
maybe have some Millennials who are
comfortable wishing fellow ma Neil's
good morning yeah or who are comfortable
you know using a musical nto target in
everyday life yeah I couldn't figure out
what I was gonna say so I'm glad you
felt little bikes I'm good I just also
had one more thought about busy tonight
oh it's almost like busy tonight only
got her [ __ ] together like last week
just in time to be canceled because I
saw a clip where she had the girls from
the white chicks like dance-off recreate
the dance-off it was the same characters
and I was like yes [ __ ] this is why we
hired you and it's like too little too
late
yeah her final show was airing on May
16th which when I first read that I was
like okay she has a few months
apparently that's next week no Jackie
and you know she's gonna be like so
email and like I mean if she's gonna
sing her song for the last time I'm
totally watching it with her like
nightgown and her Alison Lulu sites does
she wear sense every night really she's
like one good thing that she does
totally yeah anyways goodbye busy
tonight
goodbye busy tonight hello open timeslot
hello up in hindsight but also I totally
agree with you I didn't think of it that
way like I think this should be a one
late a week show it's so much pressure
it's too much pressure and you know what
it's like everyone in the world who's
been trying to fill the slot ever since
Chelsea Lately like a weekly comedy like
talk pop culture show and it's like
impossible to be done right until it's
done on every morning in the morning
yeah that's the key it's in the morning
sisters like TV executives need to stop
equating Instagram audiences with like
TV audience it's like just because two
hundred thousand people tuned in to your
Instagram stories every night does that
mean those same exact two hundred
thousand people are gonna tune in to
your new TV show it's called proof of
concept maybe having a web show first
and showing that you can turn in
ceremony answers into real audience and
that you can film a show for at least
one hour a day every day and get people
to stop working and stop breastfeeding
to watch right or to breastfeed to watch
right to take a breath
speeding brake yeah I just I can't help
but just think about how this affects me
and I think I'm it's looking real good
for me
yeah well I'm happy for you thank you
know that I am that was then
dead or good that was good okay not
sorry isn't so much news but it just
seems pertinent to the situation
considering all the Hubble ooh that's
going on about tonight's Met Gala
oh yeah CT and said she was going as a
camp counselor Lady Gaga didn't shave
her legs
wait so everyone is is agreeing with our
misinterpretation of the theme
apparently people are very confused by
the theme which is why the New York Post
has written article McHale is 2019 s
camp notes on fashion theme explained so
apparently people are really confused
about the theme because the way that
they're presenting camp which is that
it's you know flamboyance and extra with
the astragal and this that is the
makalah
always it's like right catholicism campy
this campy it's always on the next level
you know comme des Garcons
campy so des Garcons to have can't be
camp it's it's quite confusing it's dare
I say uh superfluous we're done then
yeah if last year's Catholic inspired
Met Gala was expected to be the most
controversial this year's could be its
most confused yeah on Monday the
Metropolitan Museum will host its annual
bash for the costume costume Institute
and the theme camp notes on fashion
reportedly has the glitterati scratching
their heads it doesn't help that the
theme for the party and the accompanying
exhibit opening Thursday comes from a
Susan Sontag
essay published in 1964 which you know I
can confirm that not one of the
attendees has ever read write even gala
and presario Anna Wintour is nonplussed
what does that mean they're making it
more confusing with their big words the
only advice I ever really give to
costume institute director Andrew Bolton
is whatever the title of the exhibition
is make sure that everybody understands
it immediately she said in a recent
rogue comet video adding that the theme
has created a little bit of confusion
camp not the sleeping outdoors kind but
the sashay Shantay over-the-top
varieties seen in the zany films of John
Waters are the fabulous excess of
RuPaul's Drag Race in an esoteric
concept historian Monica Sklar the
costume intz Society of America tells
the pet honestly I hope RuPaul got an
invite because like really they're
marketing what camp is like off the
backs of his show no but why couldn't
they
the theme be drag race right or just
drag right or like exuberance right like
it's unbelievably it's unbelievably
confusing and like you really just got
our hopes up with camp no Elissa
greenberg made a great call still hoping
the Olsen twins will come in over the
top Parent Trap inspired outfits and
it'd be fantastic that would be
fantastic
I'm still hoping that a few celebrities
where's Sophie charts under their
dresses in solidarity with still around
their neck which apparently ariana
grande did anyways last year yes but but
she were pillar like for comfort no we
had said like if anyone was gonna do and
be re and then turns out the Chi legit
did no I'm very much looking forward to
lots of the outfits but here's who I'm
really looking forward to most obviously
all any and all of the Kardashians who
were invited
Kris Jenner is in New York Kim is in New
York Kylie is in New York I believe
that's it Kendall oh I don't know she
literally forget about her she's fat
yeah yeah then Kacey Musgraves truly
just like can't wait to see she's going
she's going she's in New York I knew she
was going like I month ago I'm from like
an insider but I couldn't tell
and then Lady Gaga I'm really just truly
looking forward to end there has not yet
been confirmation on whether or not
Taylor Swift will show up and I'm
looking forward to her 1,000% be there
she's like she's on the board she but
this is not her year this is like the
Harry Styles Lady Gaga year yeah but the
Harry Styles of it all you know and then
she goes will she go Joe I think she's
gonna do it all because she is working
the press like when she did reputation
she did know press she did no article
she answered no questions and now she's
back on the grind and that requires
showing up to stuff be amazed and like
at least McHale is prestigious you know
I I'm really hoping that she's gonna see
him in like a pastel dress being campy
is how like and they look approved by
Anna herself where no one can say
anything that man what designer would
she go it she just has like so many like
like conflicts like you know what I mean
like with different celebrities and like
different people so it's like she can't
be sitting if she's going to sell them
Kearney who else is going selling
Kearney that she can sit with you know
yeah cuz you have to sit at the table of
your designer so probably they kinda
brings sit with whoever Gigi's like oh
yeah yeah she has model friends I have a
feeling he Aldrich oh yeah Martha Hahn I
have a feeling carly costs however Carly
classified hopefully I have a feeling
here's what I'm thinking I'm thinking
that uh Kacey Musgraves is gonna go with
Versace
okay she wears them a lot uh-huh and
they respect the hell out of her um I'm
thinking Taylor Swift I also think Lady
Gaga's gonna go with Versace because she
is was the face and she just like always
is like looking like Donatella I think
that Taylor Swift is gonna go with
something more like subtle laid-back
like a Stella McCartney you know yeah of
more refined British brand yeah or even
like a Javon chai and definitely a brand
with a woman at the helm yeah cuz
everything she's thinking him at all you
know yes she's just thinking about every
which way people will perceive it nicki
minaj's be rumoured to be coming she
went with Miss keno last year with cardi
B and then like a month later they were
beating each other up right I think
she'll go with mosquito again me too
but that's gonna be I think like if you
were if you were Jeremy Scott and you
could only bring one of them because I'm
sure they're not gonna sit together
anymore who would you put like your
brand in the hands of I would government
Lee cardi B I mean if I were Jeremy
Scott because I think she's a better
time yeah um I think she seems like
she's like more fun and probably easier
to work with and bring any more the
table and it's like what he's interested
in because his brand is in good hands
with either one of them yeah it's very
interesting um you know what I'm
interested in I'm interested in who are
gonna be the new faces like new people
who are invited yeah oh you'll hear an
interesting factoid that I found to be
well interesting you know I would this
is Hillary Steinfeld's going its ninth
Mecca I found that to be so interesting
and she posted like a video
metamorphoses of all of her looks and
it's like you can see the clear
difference in once she got that stylist
for her 21st birthday yeah and when she
was True Grit and when she was not no
and when she was just a member of
Taylor's squad like being a weiner
Somalia braces and then like someone
gave her the gift of a stylist in the
change and the change hood and I changed
my life like seeing these looks on her
like she is one of I now that I think
about it she's truly one of like my
fashion inspiration people me too who
would have thought I'd ever say and
she's also really one of the most
beautiful women you know what I'm also
interested to see I'm interested to see
some new couples and some new fake
couples cuz last year we got a show
about how much happens in a year
Haley Baldwin showed up last year with
Shawn Mendes and now she's married to
Justin Bieber it may excited to see the
two of them cuz she be Jews please yes
um and you don't have excited to see I
can't believe it
Nick and Priyanka oh my god totally and
Sophie and Joe Shelby I hope that Kevin
ending out got an invite I really hope
that Kevin and Danielle you know they're
not but like they should that
and not even because like I feel sorry
for them but because like the Jay
sisters are you a topical force and the
Jonas Brothers are an example for Jackie
I didn't even think about that like if
they don't get invited like I will
literally be heartbroken even though
like in my mind I know them they're not
gonna be there but like it's not even
because I would be heartbroken it's like
I want the force it's like I want their
their lands tappable say you know the
core for is nothing compared to the six
chicks right so I'm really excited and
that's just so crazy because last year
like you couldn't have paid me - yeah no
it's true that they were a real couple
but they're with their to it their
Burberry yeah yeah I wonder if they're
going with Burberry because that's
really where it all started for them
yeah no I mean I'm here for it that's
such a good call I forgot about the
chase sisters totally sophie turner
obviously gets invited Joe Jonas right
gets in my bed it's just it's wildly
fascinating to see who gets in bed in
and who doesn't and I would like we
could never but I would love that I went
or gave us like an in-depth you know
look at like so you you get invited by a
designer but then you also have to be
approved by Anna so it's like I wonder
how many people get invited in then
don't get approved right and like what's
the criteria for not getting approved
other than being just like can be or
just like not fashionable enough I
believe Erika Jayne is going with J cups
I don't know with who but I believe
she's going because she works with Vogue
so she hadn't get turned down I'm almost
like 90 like I'm pretty sure like one
small step for Erika Jayne one giant
step for Bravo kind yeah no I think I do
believe she's going I don't know why I
know that but I'm pretty sure no that
makes that sounds like it makes a lot of
sense
yeah and I'm curious all I : Lily showed
up like they weren't made for the camera
and as confirmed on her Instagram that
she's going which is so crazy because I
feel like last year she was probably
like having a breakdown that she had
that : Lily got to go and could not only
that they were truly like the stars of
the event no she put in the work this
year to get invited and I watched her
now in to Netflix movies where she was
supporting at best role she like wasn't
even she was barely in them and she
stole the show like I watched his movie
the new romantic on Netflix I told you
about it she's in it briefly and she's
just like incredible and the movie is so
interesting and it's just not what you
would expect an ideally I want you to
watch it I'm curious on your tape I will
do it then I also watched the perfect
date which you had situated which one
was on Noah sent any no I did not
like it from one reason and one reason
only Laura Marano she doesn't do it for
me she ruin Ally in Austin and now she's
ruining movies on Netflix she had such a
bad [ __ ] attitude the whole movie and
like she was just pissing me off like on
screen off screen
he wasn't worthy of know as Centennial's
love and I just that's all it says and
honesty justice for Lana Condor just
like one big fly I want to point out in
the movie is like Noah Centennial like
wasn't about to lie to Camila Mendes
about where he was for him until like
Lauren Morano lied for him and then he
got me trouble for lying about it you
know and like he really liked it was a
Keith turned into a bad guy like he
didn't do anything wrong
no he's just hustling and like really
he's not gonna go to Yale oh my god so
stupid
and why do you have to be Yeller UConn
like what about Colgate oh please you
know what you know like why didn't the
Ivy League or your dad's professor
school like right why can't just go to
any other school that will accept you as
you are with your good grades but is you
come like a really good school is it I'm
pretty sure it's like one of those like
never heard of like math schools like
Caltech like MIT am i right no we're
saying is a public college so that
doesn't mean it's bad no but like I
don't know I don't know I'm not gonna
speak on it but I'm just going to like
Community College yeah there's just like
so many other schools in between what we
think might be Community College and the
Ivy League I know Colgate no I don't
know why they're making it seem like Ivy
League colleges like make you into a bad
person I mean it was stupid it was
stupid
they did that go [ __ ] em that's we're
not accepting me Harvard totally imagine
if I had went to Harvard I know you
would tell life would be so boring
yeah it really would he would definitely
not be girls no job I would definitely
not be the host of the most prestigious
morning show on television
no on computers sorry I think you should
meet me for a second I feel a little
like oh well good good to go
next story a little backstop is biz news
avengers endgame passes Titanic globally
Wow in two billion dollars so now it is
the second highest grossing film of all
time only behind James Cameron's Avatar
which made 2.8 billion dollars and at
the speed that Avengers is going it is
set to pass it which is also crazy that
James Cameron responsible for the number
one and number two grosses yeah grossest
movie so far no truly avatar was gross
No
and you know whenever I think of like
box-office hits or whatever I always
think about entourage
when Vinnie gets to play Aquaman which
is just a weird like the genesis of
Aquaman like where it is now with you
know the true Aquaman
Jason mama who like Vinnie chase pales
in comparison but the whole thing was
like we want to beat spider-man we want
to beat spider-man spider-man was like
the all-time best weekend doper opener
or whatever now it's like movies like or
just keep topping one another like
nobody's been talking about spider-man
no but I think was spider-man was the
highest-grossing super clear weekend
superhero they were comparing
superheroes but Titanic avatar it's not
a superhero moment I didn't see it so I
can't say I just saw it in IMAX 3d yeah
stone as a rolling stone
so actually funny story about avatar I
was on my way to my high school trip
which one year senior in Verma's
University I mean you were about four
school you go to Poland and visit the
Holocaust death camps and it's very sad
so our flight was delayed so it was bad
weather so they had everyone you know
leave there are things at the school and
just like take your time so we went to
go see avatar so I saw it right before
my trip to Poland and it was just a
transformative week for me oh for sure
yeah that never that seems weird like
even when you're playing you have to get
there in time especially for
international well we didn't that's
irresponsible in the school maybe we
moved to another flight or something
maybe that all 40 kids yeah no those are
a hundred of us oh wow yeah you have a
good turnout that year yeah interesting
what did you like it
Poland or the movie movie well as chums
in the movie I did actually remember
liking it the headache I got a headache
from the IMAX glasses which I don't like
Poland on the other hand I feel as if it
was an important thing for everyone to
say for sure
maybe I'm sorry say I've seen Poland so
maybe I should see avatar maybe you
should anyways congratulations to the
whole Avengers team this is cool I love
breaking records and everyone is so
excited about Avengers they're equally
happens you do don't spoil oh no my god
I would never like coming up here like
that module II and Jacob Tremblay
is here Jacob Tremblay tweeted those
there's bullies at his school who are
shouting Avenger Avengers end game
spoilers out kids who haven't seen it
iPad is bullying I believe there's just
one spoiler well don't say it obviously
I'm gonna say it no no I'm totally
kidding you covered
not like I'm ever gonna see actually but
maybe I will see it no I would never
spoil it I'm not a [ __ ] I'm still upset
at my friend Rachel
Ashton Dorf who in the 8th grade spoiled
Desperate Housewives for me and told me
spoiler alert that Carlos got blinded in
the tornado and I'm so mad at your
friend Alicia yeah who ruined big little
lies by theorizing something I wasn't
even thinking about no totally spoiler
alert I'm still mad at least you two
because I was like you guys at least you
shared the dumbest theory with me it was
that's how far off I thought it was and
obviously and she claims that she liked
Jenna read the book and like nobody told
her this where I'm like here's such a
[ __ ] liar Camille she's like I think
that Nicole Kidman's husband is the one
that raped you named hayleen Woodley I'm
like no way I'm like that guy right
there I was like there's literally no
way and that's what ended up happening
crazy I'm excited for a big little eyes
to come to however I'm concerned because
the storyline for season 2 seems like
they're just like trying to escape
justice of season 1 and yeah we needed a
new storyline also I get annoyed when
like they lack like like okay in a
real-life situation like if you if a guy
was coming after you and you killed him
like that's self-defense I just tell the
police took all the time in ranked
expert housewives when they killed
Gabby's spoiler alert stepfather I was
like okay you had cause he came there to
find you with the weapon like bad like
Gaby's stepfather is now a character on
dynasty that actor he's also dad and
ugly but I know but it's like he's so
scary and like just like I just know
someone's going down because he's there
but that he's also like the lovable dad
versatile when I first saw him as a
Betty's dad in Ugly Betty he was like
home and he was like this humble guy
from Queens working yeah and he just
like loved his family so much and he
missed his wife and I just I loved him
and then litter I got chills when he was
on screen he's in dynasty and I'm
getting chills
wow that's so funny honestly good for
him just keep getting in and out work
and premium shows yes you guys I just
this is my weekly reminder if you don't
watch dynasty you have to start watching
and is the greatest show on TV scripted
right now other than Game of Thrones
obviously okay you ready for the fight
and by the way I'm talking to you too
cuz I know you know I'm just like a
little behind on Fallon but I will get
there okay third and final story in a
little sports news that can
Derby happened this weekend and country
house with a 65 to 1 odds wins the Derby
via DQ disqualification okay so the
worse way to win the first horse that
won was a two-to-one odds so that was
like the you know the obvious choice
maximum security led the Kentucky Derby
every step of the way except for the
final one into the winner's circle the
Colt became the first winner
disqualified for interference in the
derbies 145 year history leading to an
agonizing wait and an eventual stunning
reversal that made sixty five to one
shot country-house the winner Saturday
maximum security was moved from first
place to 17th behind long-range toddy
who was determined by the stewards to be
the last of the horses affected by the
interference this isn't the horses fault
so what did he get in trouble for
interfering with other horses I don't
know it's like but that's how does the
horse know maybe it was the jockey who
did it the riders of the 18 long range
shoddy and 20 country horace lodge
objections against the seven maximum
security the winner due to interference
turning for home leaving the quarter
pole we had a lengthy review of the race
we interviewed affected riders we
determined that the 7 horse drifted out
and impacted the progress of Wars will
in turn interfering with 18 and 21 bot
Express the names of these horses it's
like was their maximum security at the
game no it's so confusing yeah but like
here's the thing okay so if the horse
now country road whatever it's called
Old Town Road if he now wins the other
like the Triple Crown does it still
count because you only won by
disqualification um well if he were to
win the Triple Crown which Ike hasn't
been done watch hey wasn't done reading
Pharaoh okay but like other than that
it's a big deal Secretariat I don't
think people would be like hard pressed
about that this thing so like let's see
if he gets there you know I just can't
wait for the movie about this cuz I love
Secretariat in Pharaoh
it just happened give it a minute maybe
this is around these days is pretty
quick like I'm ready for that ty cave
movie you know that was so crazy when
wooden Elsa Mandela died like the movie
literally came out that we tax week and
now they're making movies like about
living people like people can start
playing themselves soon yeah Dick
Cheney's still alive my advice right
they could he could have played himself
innovative as [ __ ] no but what was
really innovative was Christian Bale's
makeup was in Christian oh yeah
Christian Bale played Dick Cheney that's
how shocking the makeup was that is
you need to see a side-by-side I can't
the golden globe for advice I looked it
up to see who he played because I was
like Oh does he play George Bush he
doesn't really look like him
but I guess okay and then I saw he
played Dick Cheney and I was Chuck to
the place really like an act or you know
but like his comb-over in American
hustle like still gives me PTSD no that
would be the fighter really just you
know you see movie and it changes you
that was me in the fighter I didn't see
it great movie toast movie in the leak
maybe bring that back I know now that I
have my TV's set up it's just sighting I
have so much mucus in my air it's like I
can't hear a thing
speaking of my TV setup I was able to
take in last night's game of thorns in
my new apartment
oh my god an incredible experience I
watched Game of Thrones when I was like
still drunk so it's all coming back to
me now in the words of Celine Dion but
you know for an episode I'm really like
continuously letdown because you want to
know why it's like day when we first
started watching the show they made us
feel like no character is safe even your
most beloved is gonna die so I totally
thought last night Jamie Lannister was
gonna die maybe Tyrion like on two
occasions and I was just I'm just let
down now like when I'm not devastated
over the loss of characters like that's
what Miss Sunday okay like I'm not gonna
lie like Miss Sunday so what she was
like the pure lemon I would make a wife
justice for him a Sunday justice for
Miss and a justice for Miss on they kill
seriously actually that's such a waste
of a wish but yeah I mean it's ready
written in the ceilings and also Justice
Thomas I know she's dead already so yeah
but like aventure cars I'm there of all
the characters that I like Belov Musante
yeah but like Miss Annie wouldn't you
think about her friend I think more
devastated over grey worm sorry okay
because that makes sense but they're
both like so actually miss honey's never
even killed someone like she's so pure
she's such a good adviser to Danny she's
daddy's best friend Danny is losing
everyone like yes she's [ __ ] going
mad and by the way so am i I'm with her
Danny is getting to a level that I just
can't tolerate I saw the funniest me is
like we were we do we have to tell them
what we do after but I saw such funny
humor that's like after everything
Danny's been through do what your daddy
said gonna burn the Baja cloudy and I
love to play this game after every
episode of Game of Thrones it just
because like everyone out there who
watch his game at Thrones like
thinks that they are a encyclopedia of
knowledge and humor and they like are
just the most creative funny witty
people and they're just like hilarious
and they all need to be heard on Twitter
and there are so many funny memes that
come out of Game of Thrones but there
are so many awful ones and last night I
think I found the word fun and I think
we should post it to the morning toast
let's do it because but it looks so mean
to the person who wrote we'll cut them
out okay we won't keep them okay or
there's other kind of credit anyone
wants okay I don't know say we get mad
like maybe we should attribute but like
it was and then Ben was facetiming me
like I'm talking with roads me so I was
like wait I have one that you should
post like it's [ __ ] epic and then I
think same claudia to watch his reaction
while he got it I don't get it and it
just you're not supposed to it's worse
to me that so yeah a good part of a
great I'm gonna make a parts of being a
game of Thrones fan is going on Twitter
and seeing like the funny things that
are written and pointing out like the
the things that I might have missed like
I guess last week I totally missed that
when the night king brought all the
White Walkers back to life he also
brought back to people in the crypts so
all of the Starks mr. Lewin who were
John Ramada who were buried there got
brought back to life momentarily but
dumb one that I can got killed
they all died so it didn't even matter
but I just missed that little detail cuz
apparently one of the White Walkers look
just like mr. lewin crazy Margalo and
staff yep um then also what it pointed
out I missed apparently in the scene in
Winterfell when they're all partying and
eating which looks so much fun
there's a Starbucks caught up on one of
the tables No yeah with a teabag coming
out like shut the [ __ ] up yeah really
bothers me because I'm a firm believer
other than two things that happen in
this whole series that it's the greatest
masterpiece of our time and I will tell
you the two things that don't make sense
well first of all the recasting of
Daario naharis without any notice with
someone that looks nothing like him and
we're just supposed to get on board even
though that's Liam from Nashville anyway
that we weren't supposed to get on board
we were just supposed to know that this
blond guy with long hair with big arms
is now a tiny little shrimp with black
hair right so like that piece was shaped
like that ruined like what could have
been a perfect perfect eight eight
season series show yeah it's like by the
way half the population of the world
watches Game of Thrones
yeah how [ __ ] crazy is that it was
just a huge
consistency huge inconsistency and
another inconsistency is missandei gets
her powers and her youth from the
necklace but in one of the seasons we
know Melisandre Melisandre sorry
Melisandre gets her powers and read from
the necklace in one of the seasons we
see her in the bathtub like being naked
with Stannis's wife and she's not
wearing the necklace and please explain
cuz minute you take Santos off she's an
old lady there might be some explanation
ok but so do I agree like
inconsistencies in this strike three of
a Starbucks cup you want to hear
something so crazy like even though it's
regarded as one of the best shows like
ever friends it is without fail the most
inconsistent show ever ready they had
that guy that actor John something Ben
loves him he's a good old Jewish guy
he's like oh he was rumoured to be
dating
Adriana from 90210 do you remember that
uh no okay whatever they had him on
twice as two separate guest characters
meet John he's an old Jewish [ __ ] yeah I
don't know be sure she's just like one
of those guys okay no whatever he was on
twice as a cameo like has two separate
characters like how weird is that he
went on the team with Rachel in the
other time he was like a chef
that's horrible yeah okay wait it gets
worse there's some they had a random
woman playing Carole the first season
but then she became like a bigger
character so they had the mom from it
takes two with the I can understand same
but there are so many episodes where
it's like okay so you know when we're
having a conversation they'll shoot me
from behind and you from behind so
they'll be like showing your reaction
when I'm being silent but I'm still like
like I think of so many inconsistencies
and wait one time they had a stand-in
for Monaco just like for the back of her
head and they actually like left a clip
of her in there like I'm this random
girl pretending to you Monica folks it's
the most inconsistent show in some
episodes they spell Rachel Green GRE en
e and sometimes I spell it GRE en that's
really [ __ ] up but like I feel like
that happens on so many shows TV's turn
out really quickly like there's a lot of
room for error there's a lot of goofs
that's okay but like Game of Thrones is
a masterpiece and so like first
starbucks cup like that's [ __ ]
unacceptable fifteen million dollars on
an episode of you're gonna leave a
starbucks couple you made us wait two
years for an episode and you're leaving
the starbucks on the table okay
have to see that okay putting that aside
let's talk about the episode the big
things that happened because
[ __ ] Gendry is my my Lord and Savior
and [ __ ] arias an ungrateful [ __ ] no
but like I understand
she's not a lien and he should know that
because he said that to her before like
oh my god but he didn't act he didn't
want her to because like you come with
me to storms end and well [ __ ] well
will slay the world he's just shouldn't
be romantic did he say that you have to
wear a skirt now no like he was and by
the way like the world oh my god it she
was being so unrealistic like he just
said be my lady in a romantic way cos
were married and you'll technically be
my lady but like I love you and now I
have a kingdom and you're a rightful
you're a proper lady like I was like I
that was so sad it was so sad in the
words of bow i was dick punched in the
heart I was devastated I was have a
shadow but Arya is obviously gonna like
go off and be an assassin and she'll
probably go back to Braavos and like
she's just an international a lot of
people think she's gonna go to Cersei
and take like after the last war where
will she got why why not certain because
she has and she said she this is less
time she's gonna be a wonderful right
and she is justice to serve she's I
can't okay I get like the attention from
killing that my king is like getting to
her a little bit nobody was like also
revel in it like have a treatment yeah
have sex again like come on yes she used
Gendry oh my god and now I just want to
say like truly I feel as if we need to
serve justice for tormund's because he
lost the Battle of Brienne to Jaime
Lannister and Jaime Lannister it was a
fuck-boy and just [ __ ] her oh okay
the Jaime Lannister Badal and it's like
I never shipped Jaime Umbreon she made
the wrong choice and it's like girl
you've been waiting so long I'm like now
you're like you know people lose their
virginity to the wrong guy cuz they're
young and dumb but you're old and wise
so you have you have no excuse you know
what it's like no matter how old or how
wise are like you always go with the
puck boy it's it really was a remarkable
lesson like that was the moral in the
episode like but do you think that Jaime
really has turned back to the dark side
or he's going to King's Landing to kill
his sister Oh like you think he was
being an I don't think that all of those
years of character development were for
nothing and that he's just I think he
had to tell Brienne like the only thing
that she could say that would make him
let her leave her yeah and not like
welcome to him right and not come with
him to say she's going to kill like to
protect him he had to get away from her
because he has to do this thing okay I
mean I just like love Jaime so much and
like I was really like rooting for him
and it was like a letdown moment I
didn't think for one second that he
might have like been being an actor and
if that's the case I love that also
speaking of character development I was
disappointed in the way and I don't
think like if these were real people
that this would have happened that bran
was such a cutthroat like like I think I
thought he would have totally went
something like hey guys your sister
wants me to kill you like what's your
offer not in such like a [ __ ] up way
where it's like he's such an assassin
and like those friendships meant nothing
to him because I know that they meant
something yeah I mean I actually really
thought Jamie was gonna die cuz it's
like we just saw him with Brienne they
keep making us love people and I think
they're gonna die right after I mean
right after I miss Sunday and grey
wormer holding hands and smiling and I
said to Zach people are dying yeah so
I'm not happy that Jaime or Tyrion
didn't die but I was really like
expecting it in that moment um and that
was like a bad deal for Iran to make
Highgarden yeah but it's like these
people are now losing they're losing but
they're gonna win okay but who knows who
I mean there's just so much turmoil in
Dany camp you know yeah and like I'm not
here for it I'm you know what I'm I
would love to hear your thoughts on Lord
Varys cuz I know you've always thought
of him to be the servants around and I'm
totally on his side he's out of [ __ ]
control and let me not forget she's not
the rightful heir but literally the only
thing that matters I'm on his side
because I know that he's right but it's
like cut this girl a break she took her
armies to the north she lost everything
to save these people and now you know
what's gonna happen to her she's gonna
go back to [ __ ] volantis with nothing
right where she started with nothing she
raised armies when to take the Iron
Throne and she got kicked to the curb it
doesn't have to be nothing but she's
greedy as [ __ ] she needs to really be
humbled and take a [ __ ] seat and
realize you're not though true there's a
we believe that but if you marry John
you could serve together but they said
she's too strong well okay but you can't
want everything have no right to it and
then I was right but no one's offered
her that yet but she should be she
should marry John and they should agree
together
agreed but everyone like John really is
and Lord Varys said it that best the men
who don't want to rule make the best
rulers I don't know but then like last
week John this is so [ __ ] useless and
it just like made me question him it
don't like one battle you know take down
years of service an honest man and he
made a really great speech that was like
very kingly yeah Lyanna Mormont just
like letting her to rest was truly
tragic
truly tragic and like sons
being a little [ __ ] starter yeah but you
know what she needed to do you see Ben's
beam he literally was up all night
refreshing his atrium because he thinks
he's gonna go barrel I hope he does
everyone go check it out a tech ship it
was really funny actually Ben is like oh
wait I'm sorry falling asleep and then I
woke up 10 minutes after I fell asleep
with acid reflux I thought it was
choking it was so scary I was like wow I
need to stop eating and Ben was like
still on his phone making a meme also I
like I know this is horrible to say but
like I want to I need to burn them all I
want everyone to burn damage we spent so
many seasons in King's Landing and those
people are horrible right now I don't
know why now they're like suddenly
making it seem like the people innocent
no they're evil remember what they did
to sanso like literally they took her
out back in the barn we're gonna rape
her till she died but the Hound came
right there evil monsters they're evil
man but also Cersei made them that way
because she like starves them out but
also it's sad their children be like
Mary's conceived the children like get
them oh he has his ways first got all
the children like to an orphanage
ya know there's just there's so much to
be done also we've never seen that
outside of King's Landing and Masson day
uh condoned it she said your kairos you
know cuz she said it I thought a dragon
was gonna but it was just a fem ago she
is power yeah or that
also like why didn't Danny like it's
like Danny could have done more to save
da day um I don't know she had to be she
did the right thing in that moment she
could have gone mad gotten under and
Dragon and the dragon probably would
have died cuz they had all their arrows
ready yeah um but her and grey worm like
actually they weren't mad in that moment
they turned her out and did nothing
which is all that they could do you know
what's so funny is like really the power
of the power of perspective because for
seven seasons the writers and the
producers made us love Danny she's a
queen she's the helm of feminism like we
love her pity up fierce Khaleesi
now they've really made everyone turn on
her just like with a little bit of
editing right and also just by like
taking away like things to her that
she's just emotional like she lost Jorah
I don't think anyone is understanding
the significance and now she saw some
the Sunday and she true and she's losing
John and she has nothing she has me but
you know what a good she has a football
team worth of soldiers a good ruler yeah
when they were all standing outside like
that was super sad she had a good ruler
like needs to be a little bit more like
not emotional I know that's bad to say
cuz like she's a woman but like it's not
know if it's because she's a woman or
just because she's very emotional like
when you're a king people die and when
you're
you see ones you love go to war and you
die and it's all about honor like she
has got to like tighten her [ __ ] up a
little agreed she's being emotional but
she has yet to act on her emotions she's
emotional she leaves the room she's
emotional she yells at someone she
doesn't burn down cities and so I don't
think she's gone mad yet but but she
might be mad now and I'm telling you how
many times are they [ __ ] gonna try
and reason with Cersei and lose
important character yes I'm driving over
it yeah they lost the wall the [ __ ]
wall no I agree they need to stop like
humanizing Cersei because she's truly an
evil [ __ ] but you know Euron starts
doing math and his head'll and terian
psych you're pregnant yeah and you know
as I was falling asleep laughs and I'm
like they I don't know if they like
think of like did have calendars like
back then like I don't know but it's
like when she gives birth to a baby
that'll probably be like a month or two
early and the baby's like totally find
the health a not premature like I bet
they're gonna be confused and the baby
is blonde of hair oh right but you know
but you're on his little history it's so
a strong way it's so crazy because now
we're truly like back where we started
like Jared Aries has nothing Circe's
raising bachelor children and pretending
to this man that it's her kids and it's
just all so so crazy because like she
started I was somebody kids sort see and
like now she has none I know but just
like the way to predict it and the way
to never said she's gonna have four kids
so she's not she's not she has to die
like there will be no justice in this
world I don't even care if the north
wind I just need Cersei to die yeah and
I just need a Targaryen on the Iron
Throne
people are saying sentence up for the
throne no I'm not here for all the like
respect that sounds us getting because I
don't forget because lest we not forget
literally everything that happened after
season one was salsa sculpts but not
even that it's like up until Daenerys
telling John that she can't tell anyone
about the secret she was so unassuming
so unreasonable so and again not a true
honorable ruler but to me that was the
first thing that Daenerys did wrong in
the north
she like Santa is such an ungrateful
little [ __ ] they could not have won
without Daenerys and her armies and
staved off the knight King for that long
and Sansa is like Aria saved the
northland are you she did but like no I
grew a this was a collaborative effort
either so
being so hell-bent on not liking Danny
his phase [ __ ] up to me and also if
Sansa were to take the Iron Throne it
would go against everything that she
said about the north being a separate
Kingdom that she has no I don't think
Santa wants that's not really the best
leave you know but that's not her angle
like her I think her goal here is just
to keep her family finally together in
the north and just like go back to the
time when they always like shoot arrows
at the targets and like have soup for
dinner yeah I'm gonna have Richie wants
to John there too and it's like maybe
they should get married now that's gross
because like they grew up his brother
and sister like even though what they
said was interesting was that though
that like them being related isn't a big
deal if they get married only it's it's
only a thing it's only like a weird
thing considered in the north like the
people in the north don't marry Yeah
right it's like you think the people in
North are like hillbillies I think it
really is different the Pekka thing
weren't raised together like she's his
Encinitas but they ever knew each other
they grew up on opposite sides of the
world like I could 100% reconcile them
being together when they were kissing I
didn't think it was no I don't think
it's weird at all either and I'm not I'm
not here for people being like that's a
reason why they shouldn't get married I
completely agree I think maybe a reason
why they shouldn't get married is just
because like Danny's a little crazy but
like that's it and you know what I hate
to say it but Danny's turning into her
father no but now I understand why her
father was like he was burn the mall in
King's Landing they're a piece of [ __ ]
yeah totally they kill me Sunday they
were just following orders I know I'm
just I'm I mean don't really burn them
all the way like maybe not at the time
and like I still think that's the Mad
King even though are we having any
clarity I'm like who the nitrogen why no
what I have a feeling like if they want
to make this season good I have a
feeling we're not done with that I could
enjoy you have only two more episodes
and now more than ever I'm feeling my
call about seven and eight being one
season of course the 1970 was only what
six eight episodes this is six which
really could have been three of course
it could have been one season but like
this is a cultural phenomenon and I want
I'm so sad I hope they have another
episode next week of nothing just so
that we had two more episodes after that
like I never wanted to end yeah and two
were episodes of the toasts talking
about it
Oh what are we gonna do afterwards you
should start from the beginning and
start talking about each episode I was
just really like heartbroken for Briana
and her like knight in shining armor
just ran away on a horse she said no she
should end like tormund was a
for her oh my god torment had so many
great one-liners for Malia [ __ ] my
pants - Armand is cuter chorim and is
funnier oh great and torment is sweeter
Jamie's richer still and arguably more
when Tywin Lannister dies he said that
there was no more like they weren't mine
I didn't have any more but they have
nothing that's true all they have is
like power to yield what's so
interesting is that like through the
test of time like Cersei has had her
[ __ ] ass on the throne since the very
beginning and even though she has no
kids no husband - like really when she
was like weaning she was like they're
the reigning queen Rosa called Queen
Mother
no Queen Regent Queen Regent like she
had always like a reason to be there now
she got no reason to be there but she's
still sitting down no just nutcase Eyrie
is why she's there and because of what
happened to her with like the Sept of
Baelor and like she once she went
through it she was like these people can
all [ __ ] burn but that maester who
she like brought back to the citadel and
like is so crazy and made the mountain
into a monster he's gives me chills
oh my god he's so crazy yeah he's insane
he's truly like you know he gives me
like Mangala vibes Oh for shit's like
putting people out an experiment yeah
he's a freak totally well on that note
Oh what time is it okay it's 11:30
everyone makes sure in 30 minutes to
tune in to my Instagram where I will be
releasing okay I'll just tell you cuz
like whatever it's on that may be deal
okay I wanna tell like the whole thing
okay um okay so in 30 minutes I'm gonna
be announcing the fall shows it's the
final leg of the dirty jeans so I'm like
I'm kind of sad about it like because
it's almost over
but I'm hitting all the towns that I
haven't hit yet that everyone's gonna
like that give me I'm going back to
Chicago we're doing Los Angeles San
Diego San Francisco
West Coast we're going to Toronto we're
making this a [ __ ] global tour yeah
that's right it's the dirty jean world
or and we are ending the show in my
hometown of New York which is just like
so exciting cuz I have another show here
and like over a year but what's even
more exciting is that I'm doing one of
my life's goals which was one of my
five-year goals for the dirty jeans
turned just like my career in general
was to play at the Beacon Theater and I
was like oh no I can't cuz like Jerry
Seinfeld plays there like I'm truly a
pizza collide just come here it's Jerry
Seinfeld but I guess like I am Jerry
Seinfeld because I am playing at the
Beacon Theatre January 25th everyoneís
of I ticket for you your mom your dad
your sister your brother your cousin
your friend that you don't even like
because I'm like so afraid that they're
gonna like regret
offering me The Beacon Theater cuz like
no one's gonna come so like everyone has
to come tickets are going on sale
tomorrow
just like announcing everything today
giving you the links getting you
prepared the access code patreon members
you get access tomorrow if it sells out
on patreon honestly like that's a you
problem because I'm really exactly
nowhere across be there if it happened
so I'm giving you one day to become a
patreon member the morning toast
patreon.com slash morning toast
that's on you I'm sorry if it sells out
I'm sure some of the meet and greets
will sell out but I don't think like the
entire show will sell out hopefully like
who knows maybe I don't know Marvel
problems I know everyone's like what are
you gonna do I'm like what are you gonna
do I'm going to the bank okay so on my
Instagram I'm gonna do the full
announcement with dates and everything
it'll be on the website tickets will go
on sale tomorrow 10:00 a.m. local time
which literally took maybe two hours for
everyone on my team to explain to me
what that means like okay 10:00 a.m.
I'll tell everyone 10:00 a.m. no so it's
like 10:00 a.m. in the place of so like
in in LA it'll be one o'clock here so
wherever what city you're buying tickets
for it's 10:00 a.m. for the city are
buying tickets for except so we're
planning a trip to New York and you live
in LA but you might chosen LA at 10:00
a.m. york time you got to wake up early
but for the New York show I wanted to
like make my own special time sock is
like that's like so that's noon okay
noon worldwide noon world one you know
Eastern Time you survived yeah so Wow
I'll put it all I'll make sure all the
Facebook groups everything just stay
tuned on my Instagram I highly suggest
everyone become a patreon member this
month just so you can get the tickets
that you want good seats VIP the whole
thing and then you also get access to
the 20 past episodes that are premium as
hell oh and we're doing an episode
tomorrow probably of the Met Gala like
read them I mean recap outfits drama
blind items right like we're gonna recap
the Met Gala lately as a story on the
show and then we're gonna get into it
yeah on the patreon so I'm just like
truly so excited I love you guys so much
like thanks for coming to my shows
consistently and like if you have been
and you want to come again like that's
fine too like I will not be upset and
someone who's been to a bunch of
different shows at different stages of
the tour through I can say that it
really changes every time and it just
gets better and better and by the time
she hits the vegan Karis gonna who's
gonna [ __ ] my pants
so yes check out my Instagram Gator [ __ ]
together
thank you guys so much cuz like
obviously no one would've offered me to
begin like if it weren't for you guys so
I very much done by the power of the
I'm very much grateful so thank you guys
I can with my set it okay so I'm gonna
do mine out in 30 minutes like the true
toasters will have known because they
watch live so totally we will see you
tomorrow
love ya bye
you